so here is the game has a good name
babbling a chess board perhaps or
freeing the clowns the clothes the
clowns praying the clans
okay so we have pebbles which we will
call clowns because they will be able to
move according to the following rule
every clown clones itself one to the
right and one up and disappears now this
move can be carried anywhere on the
board as long as the position to the
right and up are free and so again we
can replace our guy by two clowns and
remove him for instance in this
situation this guy cannot clown because
the cell to its right is not free so in
other words we cannot put two or more
clowns in one cell okay now the board as
you can see is a chess board what we are
showing here but the actual game is
played on an infinite board which is
infinite to the right and up we have
these unfortunate clowns inside the
prison so there is a prison which
consists of three cells as you can see
on this picture the right barbed fence
is enclosing these three cells and our
clowns want to escape the prison can you
construct a sequence of moves and you're
the boss you decide what order which
clones to clone so that the three clowns
will escape the prison and the prison
will be with no clowns
there will be no prisoners okay so let's
play the game for instance we can do
this
perhaps that now we can free another
clone from the prison and then we can
try the last clone but unfortunately
there is a lot of crowding appearing
well the game itself is very easy it's
very tantalizing really my intuitive
feeling in the beginning was sure I can
free the clowns what's stopping me but
after lots and lots of trials
one might start thinking the other way
around perhaps it is impossible well
before you move on with the video you
should probably stop it and play for
5-10 minutes and see what the outcome is
now there are two outcomes if you think
it is possible one particular way of
freeing the clones one particular game
is enough it's sufficient I don't want
to see every possible way of freeing the
clones however if you think it is
impossible
is it possible to prove that something
is impossible well that's a question
that mathematicians deal with on a daily
basis they're infinitely many games that
you can try can you feed this into a
computer well computers don't really
like infinite games the calculation has
to stop at some point so computers
perhaps are not an option
we need a human mind to resolve this
puzzle it has been solved by a human
mind and when maxim can see which
propels the problem he had a particular
solution in mind which to this day is I
believe the most elegant one it is not
possible actually to free the prison but
it is possible to prove that it is
impossible we will assign to every cell
of our board a number we'll just
basically write a number there so a move
is made like that everywhere so what we
need is to assign numbers in these three
cells so we have an old cell and two new
cells so you implicitly can use three
numbers for this but because the game is
symmetric along the diagonal
you might try only two numbers to make
the solution easier and more elegant so
something like this the old number is
eight the two new numbers will be all
right so what we want is the old number
a to be equal to the sum of the two new
numbers B so a must be equal to to be
making the old Sam equal to the new Sam
so what number can we put in the
bottom left cell in the first cell let's
think of the very first number that you
learned in school 1 1 okay let's see is
that going to work let's try one
but that forces us to put in the two
adjacent cells up onto the right 1/2 in
each of those 1 halves forces 1/4 so
suppose this chip has a certain weight
which it does the way you can think of
it is cut it in half and then put it on
the two new squares now if I take this
guy whose weight is 1/2 I can replace it
by 2 chips whose weights are 1/4 so
again the total weight stays the same in
fact in the very beginning what is our
initial weight so we have 1 plus 1/2
plus 1/2 this is what you have in the
prison which is 2 all right so let's
make a move let's replace this bottom
guy by two new clowns so now what do we
have we have 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus
1/4 but hey that also equals 2 so indeed
we've got an invariant and like by
saying suppose you can free the prison
so there is no one in the prison and we
have added perhaps along the way lots of
clowns now where are the clowns the
clowns are outside of the prison which
we can call Greenland so they are out in
the free land in Greenland so their
weights have to add up to 2 because this
is invariant but the question is do we
have enough weight in Greenland or
enough gasoline in Greenland to add up
to 2 mathematicians may find that
question a bit too hard to answer it
first because this Greenland is
irregularly it has this area that we
have to subtract the prison area so
mathematicians like to simplify the
problem
why not instead of Greenland let us
first try to find the sum of the whole
table forget about the prism but that's
still a very hard question because you
have two dimensions to move one to the
right and one up okay and so
mathematicians Thing Thing Thing can say
let's do a simpler problem a related but
simpler problem how about we test our
skills on finding just the sum of the
first row for if we are not able to do
this probably we won't be able to add up
the whole table we start adding up the
numbers in the first row and this is a
very interesting perhaps familiar to
some people some 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8 and so on and so forth if you
have taken a calculus course you will
immediately recognize that this is
something called the geometric series
with first term 1 in ratio 1/2 which
simply means to get the next term you
have to multiply the previous one by 1/2
and this keeps on going forever when I
have shown this problem two kids in
middle school the reaction has always
been this adds up to something slightly
less than two so you are a little bit
short of two because they experimented
they added up a lot of those numbers and
said it's slightly less than 2 it's
never going to quite get there never
quite going to get there and say all
right so let's see what this number is
so if this sum of the first row is some
s s is equal to 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus
1/8 and so on and so forth what we can
do is multiply everything by 2 so on the
Left I get to our sum and on the right
every term will be multiplied by 2 so
you will get 2 plus 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8 in
but now we recognize that we know a big
chunk of the right hand side from one on
this is our some s so what we have
obtained is what mathematicians love
working with an equation 2's on the left
2 plus s on the right can we solve it
certainly we will subtract s from both
sides and we will end up on the left
with s and on the right with two oops
did we reach 2 indeed we did so in this
row adds up to anything there is no
choice it has got to be 2 more generally
a geometric series is the sum of the
form a plus AR plus AR squared AR cubed
and so on where we have a first term a
and the ratio R in other words every
next term is gotten by the previous when
you multiply by are just like in our
first row so there is a nifty formula in
mathematics if this ratio is small how
small between negative 1 and 1
this sum this geometric series actually
adds up to something very simple the
first term divided by 1 minus the ratio
and this formula works for any ratio as
long as it is between negative 1 and 1
and so we can double check our previous
result here for the first row in our
situation the first term was 1 and the
ratio was 1/2 and what do we get
according to the formula 1 over 1 minus
1/2 1 over 1/2 which is our to all right
so we're going to add up the first row
as we saw adds up to 2 now how about the
second row the second row is almost like
the first one except every term is half
as large it's half of the previous one
so in other words the sum should be
half of our two which is one and now we
see a repetition of this idea on the
other rows the third row should add up
to 1/2 to 1/4 and so on and so forth
because now we can add up the whole
table and we are getting end up with
another geometric series except that
this time the first term is 2 the ratio
is still a half using similar arguments
as before we've gotten the total sum is
4 all right so back to Greenland we
really want you to check on Greenland it
is the total sum for minus the prison
Sam which is 2 we end up with 2 so it
looks like we do have enough gasoline in
Greenland it looks like there is no
contradiction because we can fill in all
of Greenland with clowns and get our new
Sam to be 2 which would mean that we can
free the prison
can we really free all of Greenland with
clowns because think about it if you
miss even one of those clowns you total
Sam in Greenland is going to be less
than 2 but 2 is our invariant we need to
have 2 so we need to fill in every
single cell in Greenland with a clone
remember we said we will free the clowns
that's how we started all right so at
some moment you say that's it I freed
the clowns
the game ends but how many moves did you
make up to that point infinitely or
finitely many basically when you say the
game ends this is a finite game so every
time you make a move the number of
clowns increases by 1 if you make 10
billion moves the number of clowns will
still be finite so can you really free
all of Greenland with infinitely many
clowns after stopping the game at some
point now because infinity is not equal
to a finite number
so that is a finite game and therefore
it's impossible to free the clowns
so with mathematicians solve a problem
they don't really stop they try to
generalize it they try to create new
games new problems and see if they are
solvable or not